welcome pleasure to see you Patrice how
are you
I'm very good I'm very good
so we're about roughly 6 000 people
listening to us so I have few questions
if you may I hope that uh they will like
give a lot of uh value for them
so of course Simon let's start by
referring to one of your best sellers
um to start with why all gratitude
Inspire everyone to take action I know
it's one of your old best sellers but um
I think it's also used with many people
it's a principle that this company for
me as a leader but also because I'm
convinced that that faulty net we have a
great vision to pursue
the vision we have at 40 is making
possible the digital world that everyone
can trust so it's go beyond just selling
product or services
in to the context or rule as cyber
security expert is quite critical uh to
protect Society from cyber risk and
attacks
so I lead the team and we want my sales
team of course to be successful but it's
go beyond simply doing businesses we
want uh them to of course find a purpose
or at least inspiration on their job and
I'm sure having you with us today will
give us a great Insight uh into how this
packet happened so my first question
will be how do we balance the demand of
uh meeting sales Target goals with the
purpose of mindsets who serve the need
of our customer
so what I think is so interesting about
those two things is they're not mutually
exclusive and the sales goals should fit
within the purpose one of the big
mistakes that I think uh companies make
is they think of the sales goals as the
end or Beyond they have no higher
purpose no higher uh contribution other
than the goal itself and so we overuse
um uh sort of uh war and sports
analogies to to hit that goal right it's
all very finite thinking as if it's the
end I like to think of business much
more like a lifestyle it's much more
like being healthy right the purpose is
to be healthy for example and there are
many things we have to do to be healthy
we have to eat right we have to exercise
we have to get enough sleep we have to
nurse our personal relationships there's
probably 30 other things as well it's
the same in business we have to have
good marketing we have to have good
leadership Goods product good you know
good sales for us all of these things
and it's hard to maintain all of those
things at very high level all the time
they sort of Wax and Wane the
opportunity is to work hard it's it's an
infinite game to keep those things
um going all the time and it is
perfectly acceptable to set arbitrary
goals within uh within that context now
most sales goals are arbitrary somebody
sat in the office and said we're going
to hit this number by this date and so
we all went and did it right which like
if you want to live a healthy lifestyle
you say I want to lose x amount of
weight by X date and you do all the
things you have to do to lose that
weight you exercise you eat right you
weigh yourself every day you met you you
count the metrics metrics are very very
healthy people like metrics if you think
about running a marathon
without mile markers it's actually
unnerving we we need to be able to count
our progress to feel like we're moving
forward it's a basic human need and so
we count uh we look down at the scale
every day some days we feel good some
days we feel bad and we hit our goal on
the right day we feel amazing like
hitting a sales goal but here's the
problem you have to keep exercising
eating and eating right for the rest of
your life you don't get to stop doing
those things and and the problem in
business is we we treat that goal like
it's the end except we have to keep
working on all those things the good
leadership the good sales training the
good culture it has to continue what I
think is more interesting than hitting
the goal is what happens if you miss the
goal
so if you look down at that scale and
you miss your goal you miss the
arbitrary number by that arbitrary date
you know what happens
nothing
nothing happened
in fact because you
've heard you're actually much healthier
now than where you have started you just
didn't predict the right day in the
right time and I think what's very very
important if we try and contextualize
goal setting within a purpose-driven
company is to recognize that those
numbers and those dates are not absolute
and if you you look at the trend data I
think it's really important to look at
Trend data because there are many teams
who you know their sales are up their
sales are down throughout the year it's
like a roller coaster they have a big
promotion and a big sales push right at
the end of the year they hit their goal
and for some reason we think that that
was good but if you look at another team
where everything is really steady and
really good morale is high and and and
and and things you know but they just
happen to miss the goal but clearly
they're going to hit it two months after
clearly we give that team nothing
and so I think it's okay to have the
goals it's good to count things but I
think what's what as we move forwards
and become more purpose-driven
infinite-minded companies we have to
start including Trend data to understand
that it's contextualized like this goal
is designed to advance something bigger
than ourselves
yeah it makes a lot of sense and I think
um I agree in the sense that you need to
set some goal because that's also Drive
Direction otherwise people are a bit
lost so uh but it's not necessarily the
ultimate objective
and uh and putting the people in motion
and as you say training and doing sports
or and cycling you have to train and you
it's a hard job so okay and then at some
point yeah you reach some some Summit
and then you're happy but it's just an
ongoing process so I'm very good Insight
so I really appreciate that as well and
and maybe talking about the as you know
the the main topics of our sales pickup
is about Elevate leaders
and um we're all talking about uh a rank
or great perspective but what I'm all
about how you know who act as a leader
so I'd like to get your Insight on how
do you define your readings
so I think leadership is one of the most
misunderstood subjects in business quite
frankly very often when we talk about
leaders we're talking about rank or
hierarchy but you and I both know many
people throughout our careers who had
very high levels of companies who are
not leaders
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we would never
trust them or choose to follow them and
you and I both know people at low levels
of organizations who have no formal rank
or authority and yet they've made the
choice to look after the person to the
left of them and to look after the
person to the right of them and we trust
them and would follow them anywhere
leadership fundamentally is the
responsibility to see those around us
rise and uh we hope that you you obey
and exhibit the qualities of good
leadership when you have a position of
leadership
but you can obey and pursue good
leadership at any rank leadership has
nothing to do with the rank or position
it's the responsibility to see those
around us rise that's what makes someone
a leader
yeah so what will be potentially as a
tip for the uh the the different
population we have as as you I agree
with you is not just the question
everybody can be readers but and maybe
the mistake that they should avoid
uh well one of the big mistakes is to
think that it's all about you
um you know human beings are social
animals
um if we could do everything by
ourselves we wouldn't need friends and
we wouldn't need a team we wouldn't need
co-workers we could just do everything
ourselves and at the end of the day we
can't do everything ourselves
um and so it's understanding that you're
a part of a machine and and the more you
help keep that machine well oiled which
means open and clear communication uh
sitting uh clear guidelines and
expectations
um being able to resolve conflict uh in
a healthy manner
um things like this help keep the
machine working and that the people who
support you uh will be there for you
because they know that you would be
there for them
um and so what great leaders do is they
they they work to be there for their
team members or those uh in in in in
their care
um remember when we're Junior
uh in our companies when we first you
know joined the company
um the company will give us tons and
tons of training so that we'll be good
at our jobs right and some people get
Advanced degrees engineers and the like
we'll get Advanced degrees so that
they'll be good at their job and if
you're really good at your job
eventually you'll get promoted to a
position where you're now responsible
for the people who do the job you used
to do but we very rarely give any kind
of training or uh uh uh sort of
apprenticeship on how to be a leader and
just because somebody was good at their
job doesn't mean they're good at leading
other people's being that good at that
job you know a good sales person doesn't
necessarily make a good sales manager
for example they're different skill sets
um and so one of the things we have to
remember when we when we occupy a
position of leadership is we now have
the responsibility to see those in our
team to see those on our team do well to
help them work to their natural best
it's not just about us and how good we
are or how good we were when we used to
do the job they used to it's a different
skill set and a different mindset
but I think you you know I agree and I
think you answer a bit of maybe an
expression about more about the
management so the people they are on the
discretion of uh leaders
um what in fact they can do for
supporting any correct order to access
it even what will be your suggestion
here
that's more like management
yeah say it again
now I say more from the management
perspective for for the people they're
already inappropriate to be a leader now
as I supported as a leader what they can
do to support and encourage in fact in
order to act as a leaders
some more and a great question
yeah absolutely great question so one of
the one of the uh the the muscles that
good leaders uh develop is Believe It or
Not empathy
um so what does empathy look and sound
like in a corporate environment
um it doesn't mean walking around crying
it's not what it means
um it means being able to see another
person as a human being not just as a
cognitive machine so for example here's
a fairly common scenario in in a in a
business you know
um a manager walks into somebody's
office and says um you've missed your
numbers this quarter you know we've had
this conversation three three times
before and if you don't hit your numbers
the next quarter I don't know what's
going to happen right that's a fairly
normal uh scenario if you inject empathy
into that scenario it goes a little
differently the manager walks into the
office or calls them up and says you
know you've missed your numbers for the
third time in a row we've had this
conversation before are you okay I'm
worried about you what's going on
um that's that's a a muscle that has to
be developed where that person feels
that someone has their back that someone
cares for them and that pays back in
spades over the course of time and
people will give their Blood Sweat and
Tears uh to serve and give back and
follow a leader
um who they believe sees them as a human
being and cares about their well-being
as a human being
not just if they're hitting their
numbers
yeah I agree so I think it's not often
where you can get search of kind of
advice or training because typically
management is about you know a process
and scale not too much about talking
about property and and how to act we are
talking about human people so do you
know where potentially your reps can
find is a small job from of course the
management but more HR or maybe advisor
from outside should come what's your
viewing well
you know good leaders are students of
leadership
and and they're fascinated by the
subject they read books they watch talks
they're constantly talking about the
subject and companies do have a
responsibility I believe to offer some
of that training
um you know good leadership training
includes skills like and I mentioned
some of these before you know um how to
uh uh resolve conflict how to have uh an
effective confrontation what happens if
something goes wrong where somebody did
something badly like how do you tell
them in a way that they'll hear that
information rather than just be
defensive you know how to have an
effective confrontation how to have a
difficult conversation
um how to listen uh active listening
where you listen for meaning rather than
listening for Words these are learnable
teachable skills and yes whatever
training department or HR uh facility
you have should provide that training as
you make your way through through the
formal rank structure so that you are
equipped for the new job you have just
like we would if you were a in a
technical job
um so yeah that's that's part of it but
also people who are who like I said you
aspire to be leaders they do their own
studying one of the things that I've
seen very successful in many companies
and it's very inexpensive in fact it's
very close to free is uh is a book club
where somebody says I want to be a
better leader
um they choose to read a particular book
and people volunteer and they read two
or three chapters a week and get
together at lunchtime or whatever on
Friday after work and they talk about
the chapters and they just have a book
club and slowly but surely that book
club grows and then finally somebody
says you know what this was such a good
book I bet I could teach a class to
other people about the subject of this
book and before you know it you have a
homegrown leadership training program
I've seen that work very very very
successfully and it's very very simple
to implement a book club
yeah very good very good advising man I
think it's a good idea we're trying to
implement this okay I agree that the
challenge is like leaders really you see
leaders where they are more against the
the outside difficulty so it's not like
when everything go well because that's
also an easy job
um and it's also especially for all
sales people when they are engaging with
customers and getting more like um uh
challenging in their Authority or
adversary so I think it's really where I
think we we see the difference between
uh real leaders and of course people do
just like a bit uh not prepared and may
not be able to object against customers
so
um so I think yeah it's part about the
risk and the way we should help and we
do see those guys performing because
they are able to turn this difficult
conversation to a more positive outcome
look every salesperson knows every
salesperson who's worth their salt knows
that sales is in large part about
relationships you know it's just it's
not it's not just a list of prices and
product attributes you know that that's
when you're you've become a commodity
um and every good salesperson knows that
if you have a strong relationship with a
client
um with a customer and the company
screws up
you know you get a delivery time wrong
um or let's say your price is slightly
higher than a comparable product that's
open on the market that's available on
the market it's the relationship that
that uh that that client that customer
wants to keep doing business with you
even if it's a higher price and even if
you screw up now and then because they
know fundamentally you're good people
that you have their backs and you're
going to try for them like every
salesperson knows that right well if we
know that that's the case with our
customers and our clients then the same
logic applies to our colleagues which is
it's the relationships if you want to
guarantee that someone's loyal if you
want to guarantee that someone's going
to be there for you put in that extra
mile then it's the quality of the
relationship it's the exact same skill
so this is what's I think actually sales
people have a head start in terms of
leadership training because they know
how to build relationships now just
apply that internally
you know I think it's um I agree and
that may also learn to be the question
around how to engage with the sea level
uh all of our sales of course as we
elevated with the discussion especially
when we talk about cyber security
um we're moving from Pure kind of
product discussion technical discussion
to a bit more okay A strategic
distribution and then you have to move
up on the organization and that's where
you have to have the the people engaging
with the suitable organization so
um and you know that I will say sea
level or c-squit does not want to make
time for sales rep because they're
consider not necessary valuable for them
uh they want to meet with advisor uh who
understand their business issue so what
will be your advice here for my sales
team to how to communicate with a
suitable customer and how they can build
trust with them
so um one of the things that I learned
from Jack Daly who's a famous sales
coach is he said the average number of
questions asked in a bad sales meeting
is about seven where the average number
of questions asked in a good sales
meeting is about 32. and so it's not
coming in and just throwing up you know
a product attributes or what what we can
give you because that's all about you
it's about learning to listen and
learning uh to pay attention and goes
back to those listening skills and at
the c-level executives you know we don't
know what their stressors are you know
there are some Basics they know they
need to do basic security because that's
the world we live in but why you over
somebody else and by asking questions
and listening not to try and find a way
to to get your product in there but to
genuinely genuinely genuinely try to
help them solve a problem the best sales
people sometimes say you know what
I hear what you're what you're trying to
do and I'll be honest with you
um we're not very good at that but I'm
gonna put you in touch with somebody who
is that builds trust
um you know I'll I'll tell you a funny
story with me when I was starting my
career
uh and I started my my I had a marketing
consultancy it was my my first little
business that I started I remember
coming from the advertising world where
we would talk to clients and we would
tell them we were great at everything
when we weren't
um and Trust would very quickly
deteriorate because they would find out
very quickly that we were junk in
something that we claimed we were good
we got the sale good but we destroyed
the relationship you know that's a
short-term mentality and I remember I
was I decided I was going to change that
and I would go meet with clients and
they wanted me to do all this work and
I'd say okay before we move on I want
you to know I'm extremely good at this
thing that you want me to do I'm pretty
good at this thing you want me to do I'm
acceptable and this thing you want me to
do and I'm terrible at this thing you
want me to do so what I recommend is let
me do these things
and hire somebody else and I'll partner
with them for these things
and the result was they actually wanted
to work with me more because I was the
only honest person in the room all the
other sales people all the other
companies that they were interviewing
said that they were great at everything
which everybody knows is a lie because
nobody's great at everything
and so the irony is the irony is by
admitting my weaknesses I actually built
trust and built and built better
long-term uh business relationships
now a very good I think it's uh a very
good point and I agree often that sales
are especially when you started or it
tried to say yes to everything and uh
not necessarily expose a bit of where we
are our weaknesses and I think it's uh
it's a good point you can't be as you
say it's a it's a line we can't be good
on everything so uh and putting the
emphasis where we have a very strong
value that may of course build this
Trends or very good advice on this one
so I appreciate that so
um
another topics which is more about you
know in honestly we are facing a huge uh
skill shortage so it's like uh
unfortunately the the Cyber crimes and
uh the people they want to embrace cyber
security Journey are very limited so
we're talking about the Gap about 2.7
million people so it's massive and
that's called wine so we have few
initiative at Fortinet
um on top of of course trying to sell
product but also try to push Young
Generation or even veterans we have a
program in the US to embrace in fact
cyber security
job so
um and here in this context of
recruitment which and retention which is
very big big challenge for for us
they're all very critical and and to
address them we need to drive engagement
and I would like to hear from you what
engagements mean to you or better say
how do you get your people love their
job
right so
um we don't have to like our jobs every
day but we do get to love our jobs every
days like you don't like your children
every day but you love your children
every day so having a a hard day you
know that that's fine but the question
is is what do we fall in love with and
at the end of the day the reason
um uh that we Stay or Leave a job is
because how we feel about that job you
know I think we we misunderstand when we
think people just leave for money if
they just leave for money then they
never really had strong feelings of the
company in the first place right because
when people feel loyal to the company
they turn down jobs that offer them more
money or if it's so tempting and the
numbers are so high then they go to
their company and say listen I was
offered this job it's very tempting
there's a lot of pressure but I don't
want to lead is there anything you can
do to help me stay right so and you and
there's the point is is there they're
open about it and and what makes people
want to have that conversation like I
said is that they're seen and heard
um the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills also help us as parents and they
help us as as as spouses or as
boyfriends and his girlfriends these are
valuable skills in life
you know
um and I think that we forget that we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
as if those things are opposite it's a
terror I hate the term soft skills hard
skills and human skills and the more
that we invest in human skills in
addition to the hard skills that we're
teaching the more people feel like
they're growing as individuals I'm a
better version of myself now than I was
when I started at this company because
the company is actually helping me on a
in personal growth
um uh WD-40 which is a company that I
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
um uh they train their managers to be
coaches so literally like Executive
coaching training that kind of thing but
they train their own people to do to
have that skill set so that they're
equipped to help their people who have
challenges and especially with younger
generation you know the younger
generation is asking companies to
provide everything you know we want to
have our sense of belonging our sense of
community our sense of personal growth
our sense of purpose to come from work
work it didn't used to be like that 40
years ago and so and so there's a huge
pressure on companies and so I think
what entices people into the company and
into the industry is not just come and
do cyber security you know there's a
percentage of people who are you know de
facto interested in that but rather tell
them the kind of experience they're
going to have tell them what they get
from the company and you'll find it
remarkable how many people will all of a
sudden be interested in the in the
category in the company because of what
they get holistically not just what they
get from the product
yeah I think it's uh it's a very good
point I think it maybe uh something that
uh unfortunate we're not necessarily
doing a lot of communication but uh we
do see such of uh I would say Dynamics
in the IIT industry the average of let's
say staying in campaign is about like
three to five years and we have a lot of
people that have been there from almost
10 15 years so it's uh that's my case
this example but so that's confirmed
that um when you you get a company where
there is a opportunity to grow uh if
there's of course uh option but I should
earn more you're able to have a
discussion and then they of course they
see value they can of course uh provide
you the uh the requests I think that's
what we're doing at 14. I don't think
we're doing well on communicating to to
the the employees or the culture and uh
yeah we also uh we also try to
um on top of you know what people are
doing and we asked to do the job with
your sales or whatever pre-sales is we
also try to encourage
um uh Innovation or initiative so
because that's on top of their job so
and because we do see that the value is
to get this from the ground and not just
the the top saying okay that's what you
have to do and I think we try to
encourage this as more virtual aspect
but foreign
and we have to remember we have to
remember what what gets measured gets
done we have to remember that the you
you know it's I hear this all the time
you know companies talk about we we want
our people we encourage our people to be
Innovative and we encourage our people
to look at problems differently and try
new things but when you look at the
recognition and reward programs and
structures they only get uh recognized
reward or incent or incentivized based
on hitting Financial targets and so for
all the talk of what we want our people
to do if there's no formal recognition
or Rewards program that recognizes and
rewards the behaviors
then you're only get going to get the
ones that are rewarded
um uh uh and so like I said the best
companies have a little more holistic
approach it's totally fine to recognize
and reward for performance but it needs
to be balanced with some other
attributes as well
yeah I think it's a very good point I
think we do a bit but I don't think
we're doing the best here it's of course
as we have to drive a public listed
company
and that's create a kind of a special
pressure because it's more quarterly
result and it's all about number
investors are looking about the bottom
line and the just metrics so that's tend
to drive management to listen more about
shareholder and then listening from at
least what they added initial uh think
on okay we want to build this and we
have more Innovation so we agree that um
often company as as we do in fact are
trying to drive a bit more on the
metrics which find you know aligning
with the investor and not too much on
creating this uh condition for an
ongoing I would say draw and development
so which are more about rewarding people
on innovation
right well now you're giving me a
soapbox you know which is some some 30
on one-year-old you know financial
analyst who's putting pressure on the
company to hit certain numbers doesn't
care about the company they care about
their own bonus
um and so you know companies are making
decisions to help some 31 year old
analysts get their bonus
um uh uh you know it's as opposed to
making decisions that are right for the
company and right for the right for the
customer
um and that's a whole different
discussion some of the you know there is
a there is a sea change that recognizes
the pressure That Wall Street puts on
companies isn't necessarily good for
business and the question is well how do
we how do we push back how do we stand
up to it
um uh again you know part of it is the
the recognition and reward you know most
senior executives are compensated you
know sometimes almost entirely based on
the price of the equity uh that's a
different discussion
um but one of the things that I've seen
some of them uh more forward Progressive
thinking um public companies are doing
is they're still saying that they're
they're shareholder driven but what
they're doing is they're looking at
their shareholder base and they're
bifurcating it they're dividing it into
two buckets which is you have your
short-term uh investors who they don't
actually care about anything either your
values your purpose nothing if you're
doing well investment of you to do badly
they dump you they don't care they don't
believe in your management team nothing
they're gamblers and then you have your
long-term investors who uh believe in
the management team they believe in the
vision
um when you when your stock Takes a
Tumble or a misstep is made they don't
abandon you they're there to support you
because they believe in something and so
some of these more Progressive thinking
uh shareholder driven companies are
saying we're shareholder driven by this
group we ignore this group because these
are the ones who have been our partners
just like a good customer just like a
good employee they're loyal they help us
through thick and thin and so we do pay
attention and want to support them these
ones will they'll be there anyway if we
do better you know if the market goes up
they're there if the market goes down
they abandon us so why were we taking
advice from them so that the to to think
of your shareholder your shareholders in
two buckets I think is is a is a very
good way forward it's a very good first
step
I agree and I think we it's always the
as you know leading the company the
group of video we need to make sure that
uh we're driving in Federation where
it's more strategy I'm not just
listening about these streets and I
think it's it's often difficult because
if it's uh if I refer to Fortinet uh we
have the the two two co-founder which
are you know as my same age as me and
the they're talking about what we'll do
in 10 years 20 years so it's quite I was
unusual in this Society understood
because often you know you just want to
cash out and then okay they care about
themselves and and here it fortunate
it's more about you know long term you
know we're buying real estate we're
building in fact a new countries to be
helping if I can play to enjoy the the
workspace and uh so that's also maybe
something that uh I think we do
differently at Fortinet not necessarily
communicating too well but uh I think uh
here at this the direction and what I
think a good company should do and I
think we're doing a bit in space so on
uh but I greatly this challenge about uh
driving the the street it's also good
because we do reward everyone so we have
kind of a an equity that um available
for everyone so everybody get a bit of a
you know a piece of the this uh straight
reruns but on top we have a record is
the 40 chance so we have a quarterly
um kind of a review where we we Grant uh
some some price for any any idea you
know Innovation whatever UOB sells admin
or you're the an r d guys or be just
like a receptionist and so we really try
to recognize in fact everyone so we have
these mechanisms that we do on the
quality business but I think we should
do a bit even more
love that
um so maybe next topics about uh you
know we as fault in it we we just
crossed 10 000 people it's quite a
company was uh started 2004 uh and
that's quite a good Milestone and uh and
we we have we have a very well balanced
kind of uh uh uh people because oh rob
you come let's say 40 from North America
and the rest outside which include
Europe and Asia Pacific so typically the
the population is uh you know very
Diversified we have a Japanese Korean
Chinese European French like me and uh
so but I think it's the it's about the
overall I.T industry and I think we're
doing overall the iTunes and unfortunate
a bit uh we're doing poorly on the
gender diversity and
um I think engagement also referred to
increase inclusiveness right so
fortunately we of course we try to to
commit on hiring so setting kind of goal
but I think maybe the right approach
promoting and retaining of course
talented people at all level in the
sales organization respecting of course
the gender diversity but an example
um we have the data proved that
typically when you hire women sellers uh
they when they're on the team they are
you know the the profitable business
grow Innovation grows and cooperation
improves so let's see we can set Target
for hiring but how can we help our
leaders to recognize talented people
respect of diversity and deal with the
deal with it to drive the change
well that's a loaded question isn't it
um you know if if you have somebody in a
leadership position who who literally
doesn't respect uh uh diversity and and
inclusion
um you know the question is why are they
in a leadership position
um uh uh so it's it's a bit of a loaded
question now I understand the challenges
you know if you do things with intention
if there's an intention to go out and
find something you know you're more
likely to find it and I also think what
what companies with with resources can
do is build their own bench which is go
to universities you know invest in the
programs that will train the people
train uh in this case as you said some
gender diversity so that they have the
skills and then uh and offer them the
potential for jobs when they come
through the the program so you set them
up in other words build your own bench
because I've heard this from companies
before which is you know we'd love to
but the talent's not there you know so
go build the bench if you have a
long-term approach to this stuff it's
not about solving a problem in a month
you know it's about solving a problem
um so that it's sticky so it's not just
a reaction but rather it becomes
inculcated and built in into the fabric
of the company
um and and I go back to leadership
training again
um which is what good leaders recognize
is that a diverse Workforce brings
diversity of points of view if everybody
looks like me went to similar school as
me you know uh was was brought up like
me
um then we're all going to have kind of
similar uh points of view on some of the
challenges we face but when we have
people with different racial um
backgrounds or or different or different
genders we you know some people grew up
in Europe versus America or Rich versus
poor they bring entirely New
Perspectives based on their world view
to a problem and the more diverse
perspectives we have on any challenge it
means the more options we have to solve
that problem and this is not surprising
to me that when you say we have a more
when we have more diversity we're
actually better at the thing we're
trying to do that makes perfect perfect
sense and so I think one of the things
to do is for Senior Management to to
hammer away that this is essential for
us it's important for us
um and that uh uh that leaders will are
going to be expected to embrace this
um that we're going to be judging our
leaders and their ability to do this to
build
um uh more diverse teams and to go out
into the marketplace to to before before
these some of these young people start
looking for jobs and start training them
in the skills that you want
um and setting them up it goes to what
we said before which is we want to make
you a whole person we'll give you some
of the technical skills and some of the
human skills and then when you join us
you're going to be a better prepared uh
a person a better prepared employee to
join to join our team because we've
already set you up for success with hard
skills and human skills
I agree I think it's also may help on
this uh I would say funny to people
because uh we of course we we think that
maybe the the right people are the
people that has been getting the skill
from the the school or university
specifically to the sector but uh
especially in in this industry you can
have people they can quickly learn and
they can really adapt and then and of
course try to bring different view
different uh you know go to market
approach by the expense can also help to
you know
um improve in fact the way you are
engaging these customers so I think it's
a something and that we do we do of
course activity like I was mentioning
that we have this veteran program in the
us where we try to help them to find a
new job uh we have similar kind of
initiative as well with the uh as we are
part of the world economic Forum so and
here is about training so we we provide
info free uh you know kind of uh so you
can do it online uh how to get the in
minimum and basic skill about cyber
security and then you can get this
certification and then you can
potentially apply for a job anywhere in
the world so let's uh I think
yeah I think it's really helping a bit
on trying to enlarge a bit more you know
the audience because at the end cyber
security is about
um securing the the digital life that
we're all going through and uh yeah and
what we I think what's what's missing
here is that there is a bit of a when
you go to school or even your kids that
are maybe at uh very young it's not
often where they can get the the the the
minimum skill about how to you know uh
uh drive and live with this uh social
media and digital life so there is
almost no expertise so so we're building
a bit of books here to help young people
do you know what's the what's the right
approach what uh not to do and but of
course at the end is trying to um create
a bit more vocation in this place and
that's uh that's true now and that's
whatever the the general so is really
trying to bring more different people
across the world
is a great is a great solution foreign
slightly different than other industry
because we are it's like police and you
know the the we're fighting against
kinds so it's like you you have really
the in fact the um it's an ongoing
process you are I'll say the good side
to try to build in fact um you know the
protection for for the customer for the
for yourself in fact to uh to prevent in
fact any any big challenge that will be
in digital life so it's really uh modest
mission that that is people when they
are applying for the Cyber accessibility
job and for special company they have a
long term they can they can see on top
of course learning a pretty nice model
and so on
it's maybe the the why you are working
for the government company
so um no I think it's all of course a
lot of very positive uh elements here
that um of course help to drive the uh
the evolution of the of our business so
um
um yeah any maybe further I would say a
point that you want to um uh give advice
to my team and to the to the audience
that listening about you know you know
the all those topics on maybe specific
area that you think makes uh more
relevant
well I am you know my latest obsession
is this concept of finite and infinite
games and I've I've mentioned finite
mindedness or infinite mindedness a
couple times why we've been discussing
this goes uh back to the mid-1980s a
philosopher and theologian by the name
of Dr James cars Define these two types
of games finite games and infinite games
a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and an agreed upon
objective football there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner that means there have
to be losers
then there are infinite gains infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means new players can join
at any time
um and sometimes you don't even know who
all the other players are
uh the uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible
um we are players in infinite games
every day of Our Lives whether we know
it or not nobody wins education for
example you know you can come in first
for the finite amount of time you're at
school when we agree upon the time frame
the school year and we agreed upon the
metric grades but nobody wins education
uh um and likewise nobody wins business
there's no such thing as winning
business it doesn't exist right but when
we listen to the language of so many of
our leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't always know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one being the best or beating
their competition
based on what
based on what agreed upon time frames
metrics and objectives and this is a
problem because when we play with a
finite mindset in an infinite game when
we play to win in a game that has no
Finish Line there are actually some very
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big one being the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation and the decline
of innovation and so we actually have to
adjust our mindset to fit the game that
we're playing and in the case of cyber
security you know you're you're actually
trying to prevent crime from happening
the criminals aren't trying to beat you
they're trying to do more they're just
trying to get more money they're just
trying to trick people they just want
access they actually don't care about
you and your cyber security they're just
trying to do more crime right it's an
infinite game
and you don't even know who all the
criminals are there's no such thing as
winning cyber security it doesn't exist
it's an ongoing Cat and Mouse game and
so you have to have the right mindset
for the game you're playing and in this
case it's not about winning it's about
constant Improvement then it goes back
to that analogy that we discussed right
at the beginning when we talked about
the lifestyle of business versus trying
to treat it like a finite game right
which is it's not the end of the the
financial year doesn't symbolize the end
of the game it's just a marker it's just
a waypoint and so all of these things
that you and I have been discussing is
all about constant Improvement you'll
never be perfect at any of it ever
that's not the point the point is that
you're constantly working to advance and
you're constantly saying how can we be
better how can we better relative not
only to our to the other players in the
game but also relative to the criminals
in the game because you could be the
best quote-unquote uh compared to all of
all of your uh of the other companies in
the marketplace but if the criminals are
smarter than you then then there's no
point yeah
um so so I think that's that's to adjust
our mindset to play for the game we're
in which is the game of business and
especially cyber security which really
is an infinite game
um I think it's really really important
and having the the people so giving the
time to continue to learn so it's like
and that's what I'm saying to the team
is like it's anything again what you
have to learn you have to learn every
day you have to it's a new fight every
day so it's always like this uh you know
normal curve about learning and there's
no age to stop learning so I think it's
really a part of the uh how you can
evolve yourself and being more better
fitting here and so on
um exactly maybe last point which is me
more about the what we have all uh uh
you know dealt during the last two years
and uh and due to these uh covet and
pandemics is really about we're talking
about the um you know the post era of
kovid and uh coming maybe hopefully in a
few months uh and we've been and most of
our sales have been in fact engaging
virtually like we're doing right now
which is not necessarily the best we all
have to be in the same place as you but
uh any any you have been doing a lot of
course I saw your video and also uh you
will thank you Thursday it's also a lot
of the Great Value that create in fact
the energy for people especially stay at
home any any advice on on how people
should continue to evolve and prepare
maybe for the postcode area
yeah it's a great question it's a
challenge that you know is is now a
pervasive
um uh one of the things we have to
remember is that just because
um the business can function with a
distributed Workforce with an online
Workforce
um we know that there's a sacrifice you
know it's harder to build trust you know
if you if you've joined the company
during covid you've never physically met
any of your your colleagues or
co-workers you know and you know it's
much harder to build trust when we don't
meet each other we take for granted that
we go to the office that you know the
little brief interactions we have at
work where you walk past somebody in the
hall and say hello or the talk going
into the meeting and the talk coming out
of the meeting and bumping into somebody
building oh I meant to tell you
something or do you want to grab of
coffee know one of these things by
themselves does anything but over the
course of time they contribute to the
building of trust to the building of
Human Relationships in an online context
we don't have any of the in-between all
we have is the meeting we log on WE log
off that's it and so what a lot of
companies
um um haven't recognized is that
building Trust online is possible but it
actually requires more work what used to
happen just relatively organically now
has to be now has to happen
prescriptively
so for example
um I'm a huge fan of the Monday morning
huddle we do one on our team we're on
Monday morning the whole team comes
together
um and it's there's no discussion of
work or deadlines or workloads or
anything it's a human call where we
simply say what's on your heart and mind
and then we answer some funny or
poignant question that's posed To Us by
the person who's leading the Huddle that
month
um and and we simply talk about
ourselves and you learn a lot about
somebody you know somebody'll say oh I
had a great weekend with my kids and we
went you know we went hiking I didn't
even know that they had kids you know or
somebody will say to be honest it was a
really hard weekend
um my father has cancer and he's in the
hospital and he took a turn for the
worst and uh and we start to see each
other as human and we start to empathize
and we start to create relationship
and we start to get to know each other
but it's done prescriptively it we we
make it happen
um I'm also a huge fan of of turning on
a zoom for example and just working like
we're not actually working with each
other we're just in each other's screens
as we're getting our own work done it's
nice to have somebody there I'm also
believing about a huge fan of the
telephone
um you know zooms are tiring especially
when you have them all day
um you know it's fake uh you know very
often you know I'm looking at a DOT at
the top of my screen so that you'll
think I'm making eye contact with you
but really I'm just staring at the dot
at the top of my screen or if I'm
staring at you sometimes the placement
of the camera in the screens what you
see is this but I'm looking right at
your eyes you know yeah
um and so I think a telephone believe it
or not is actually a much better way to
connect with somebody especially when
someone's distracted when you can see
that someone's doing email you know
while you're talking there's no actual
polite way to say can you stop doing
that and listen to me please you know
and we just sort of
do it on the telephone if you hear
someone's distracted you go hello you
there they go sorry sorry you know you
can actually catch people and I find
that those interactions you know I'm a
Pacer I like to Pace when I'm on the
phone when I'm thinking I can't Pace on
Zoom which means my thinking is junk
right when I'm on a phone call I can
walk around I can walk around wherever I
go and I can talk to somebody and I can
be much more engaged I think we
especially for sales people
use the phone pick up the phone how are
you wanted to check in with you you know
have a conversation without Zoom uh I
actually think it's actually much better
for building relationship believe it or
not having zooms occasionally is great
too but I think we've under we've
forgotten we've forgotten how good the
phone is
I I agree and I think it's uh we may
have been abusing too much about this
video conferencing he's definitely uh
yeah a great that did a great value for
be able to engage especially when you're
not in the same place because traveling
was also the other challenge when you
are doing this job so you're able to at
least uh capture potentially 30 minutes
of uh you know a person that may not
necessarily give you the time uh if it
was normal and then you have a normal
meeting we'll take more so there's a
value but on the other side I agree with
not necessarily always very uh true it's
a bit fake so and um and uh so what
we're doing here is also we try to uh
um help the overall setting people on
leveraging uh what we call digital
selling tools so it's uh and that's a
bit strange because you feel okay
selling was more like a human kind of
interactions but we discovered there's a
lot of uh preparation about getting the
Insight from the customer that are
leveraging in fact tools where people
are going to the website they choose
some data whatever or correctly to your
website they look about some aspect of
the business or product so we're
building that but that's also a bit of a
cultural let's say uh not Clash but
evolution because the old-fashioned
people like myself never use that young
people Millions
they are jumping on these kind of tools
and uh and as you have to balance the
team it's uh you know trying to bring
everyone taking a bit of value here why
as you say taking the phone is also the
the great value
and I think you're touching upon
something that's really important which
is about balance right which is if the
pendulum stays only with the old timers
then you're going to miss opportunities
to be leveraged from the digital world
but if the pendulum swings too far to
you know young people who are just
really good at the digital stuff then
you end up making a commodity out of
yourself and you forget some of those
valuable sales skills that are that are
hard to teach in a classroom but there's
things that you learn over the course of
a career and so it's finding the right
balance of those very human skills and
those and that digital content and the
young have something to earn or learn
from the uh experienced and the
experience have something to learn from
from from the people who are who are
looking at the world as a blank slate
and I think it's striking it'll never be
perfect but you want to play here rather
than here and and and so I think there's
value in both
I agree but I think it's uh it's a very
good point I think we as we're looking
hopefully uh a more positive outcome
this year I think uh we do encourage a
lot on we call it like fresher events so
we are trying to meet somewhere whatever
and then having this kind of discussion
that uh as we have been missing for some
time now and and as also we're doing a
bit of a kind of sport sponsoring it's
also the place where I think you can get
contact with people on complete
different contexts so it's not talking
about business they may be passionate by
the sport that we are sponsoring and
it's a good way for engaging so uh well
I really appreciate Simon uh in fact the
uh the discussion and the talk really
The Exchange I'm sure that uh all the
people that will be listening will uh
learn a lot so um that was very good and
uh to becoming a bit at the end of our
conversation I thought it very educative
at least for myself and uh I'm sure that
all the great Insight that has inspired
team are and they are looking in fact do
their job slightly differently and I did
mine already so even I'm learning still
today and um you made us understand even
more the importance of the human
elements in fact on in being or based at
work but also getting the feeling of
fulfillment so thank you so much Simon
and for being with us today
thanks Patrice thanks for having me good
luck to everybody take care of yourself
and take care of each other
thank you